Today I want to take a little bit of a
closer look at a scene from Alfred
Hitchcock's masterpiece vertigo.
It's an early scene in the movie when
the retired detective Scotty,
played by Jimmy Stewart visits an old
college friend,
Gavin elster.
Specifically,
I want to look at how hitchcock blocks
this five minute and 22nd scene and how
is staging of the characters adds to the
story I married into it now.
I should say that there are two ways to
look at the scene from the perspective
of a first time viewer who has to take
the information it presents at face
value or from the perspective of someone
who's already seen the film and knows
the true intentions and outcomes of
what's revealed here.
I'm going to take a look at this from
the second perspective,
which means that there's going to be
spoilers,
so just a heads up,
so if you've seen vertigo,
you know that in this scene Gavin elster
is spinning and elaborate lie in order
to create an alibi so that he can get
away with murdering his wife and his
plan.
Scotty is the alibi.
Gavin tell Scotty that his wife has
possessed by an old spirit,
ask Scotty to spy on her,
then switches his wife out for an
actress who plays that part cleverly
exploiting Scotty's desire and his
vertigo,
Gavin and the actress murder his wife
and leave Scotty traumatized,
believing that
the wife committed suicide.
The scene in question,
the one in Gavin's office at his ship
building business,
comes only 11 minutes into the film and
comprises Gavin's attempt to learn
Scotty into his deception.
How did you get in the shipbuilding
business?
I'm married.
The scene starts with Gavin seated at
his desk and Scotty standing behind a
chair in the center of the room.
In the beginning,
it's Scotty who's dominant.
He's asking questions moving around
Gavin's desk,
leisurely inspecting various objects
like a retired detective,
Mike by acting and sitting rather coyly
Gavin lures.
Scotty into his space and his confidence
under the illusion of sincerity.
What was it like to hear?
How long have you been back?
Almost a year,
Scotty.
He continues his inspection moving to
the other side of the room to see an old
picture of San Francisco.
His back is turned just as Gavin makes a
key confession.
Yes,
I would like to live here.
Then kinda excitement.
A freedom.
It's that freedom.
He desires freedom from his wife that's
launching this cruel plan.
Of course the audience can't know it
then,
but hitchcock's foreshadowing.
It's there and it's in the staging to
while he sits.
Gavin is in front of a window that shows
a shit behind being put together piece
by piece,
not unlike the story he's about to spin
for.
Scotty.
Would you like a drink now?
No,
I don't think so.
A little early in the day for me.
Scotty moves toward Gavin again and sits
in the center chair asking him the
purpose of their meeting and hear the
power changes hands.
As Scotty sits in the hot seat,
Gavin stands and begins to tell his
story.
He moves around the desk and up a couple
of stairs so that he's towering over
Scotty even higher.
I want you to follow my wife.
No,
it's not.
They were very happily married.
Well,
I'm afraid to sound harsh.
May come to someone.
Did.
When Gavin makes his big reveal that his
wife is being supernaturally possessed,
hitchcock brings them in closer to
Scotty so that the ankle is even more
extreme far now from being coy,
Gavin's blocking becomes aggressive and
the next thing that happens is perhaps
the most interesting moment in the
scene.
Kevin and Scotty remain fixed in their
positions,
but the camera dollies backwards to
bring them both into frame.
Now the camera moves all over the scene,
but this movement is the only that
really calls attention to itself.
This is a reminder that for hitchcock
blocking involves the position of the
camera too.
There are three elements in this scene,
not just to Scotty expresses his
disbelief at the situation,
and Gavin sitting again,
softer in tone,
acts like he understands.
Sorry,
I wasted your time.
Thanks for coming in.
And Scotty.
Scotty,
he gets up and moves toward the door to
leave.
Gavin lets this happen because he knows
that too.
Really Rope Scotty and he has to make it
seem like it's his own choice.
Scotty apologizes and Gavin moves into
his space again and before Scotty can
say anything,
Gavin starts in on the details of his
life,
how his wife seems to fade in and out of
her personality,
how she wanders around to odd places and
Gavin himself is wandering in the second
room which is raised a few steps like a
stage and Scotty moves to the chair on
the opposite side,
like an audience member watching
his performance.
I've followed her one day wash check
coming out of the apartment.
I went,
I didn't know even walked a different
way.
Got into her car and drove out to golden
gate park.
Five months,
sat by the lake,
staring across the water,
the pillows,
the stand on the shore,
you know,
portals of the past.
Is there a long time without moving?
I had to leave.
Get back to the office.
When I got home that evening,
I asked her what she'd done all day.
She said she did not have to golden gate
park and sat by the lake.
That's a speedometer on her car.
She that she drove 94 months.
Of course,
what Gavin is doing here isn't
recounting details,
but planting them in Scotty's head
details that will match with his
actresses actions in the following
scenes.
This layer of stage performance is a
stroke of genius on Hitchcock's part
because on one level,
vertigo is about the power of film and
the power of narrative,
how a really good narrative can
manipulate us,
whether it's for the purposes of
entertainment or something more
sinister.
The narrative laid out for Scotty in
this scene will drive the whole rest of
the story.
It'll drive Scotty's actions in the
first part of the film and eventually
it'll drive his own obsessive narrative
creation and the second part I've got to
know this guy where she goes and what
she does before I get involved with
doctor.
Talked to the doctors at all are
carefully.
When Gavin steps back down into the
lower room,
the monologue ends and the conversation
resumed.
Scotty gets up from the chair to protest
Gavin's request for help,
but he's moving toward him.
Gavin mirrors his movement and
approaches Scotty entering his space
again.
This time with his final barking,
a simple request.
We're going to an opening of the opera
tonight with dining into Annie's.
First.
You can see how then the scene ends with
Gavin literally leaning into Scotty and
Scotty finally relenting.
The trap has been set.
Hitchcock even frames it so that the two
are overlapping.
I've always loved the scene in Vertigo
in college.
I used to diagram it out in my
notebooks,
trying to figure out where he put the
camera on what lenses he used,
but it's the blocking for these five
continuous minutes that are the real
mark of hitchcock's mastery of the form.
The scene is small and often overlooked,
but it holds up the rest of the film.
How many other directors could
choreograph this conversation in such a
way that it works like a dance where one
man is leading and performing and the
other is a spectator and a patsy without
knowing it.
Yet both Gavin elster and this scene
have hitchcock written all over them.
In other words,
I don't think it's a coincidence that
the man himself isn't too far away.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I really did diagram the scene in my
college notebooks and I encourage you
guys to pick out a favorite scene of
yours with complicated blocking and,
and do the same.
I think it can be really illuminating.
Um,
thanks to squarespace for sponsoring
this video of the nerdwriter is my full
time job,
so pledges and sponsorships on this
channel help me keep my nose to the
grindstone just to make more videos,
which is what I love to do.
And squarespace is actually really
great,
really professional looking,
sleek,
intuitive websites.
You don't have to know coding to make
one and you can get a free domain.
If you sign up for a year,
you can start that free
trial@squarespace.com.
And if you use the offer code nerd
writer and get 10 percent off your first
purchase,
squarespace,
you should.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next Wednesday.